des baguettes thierry vilar en a fait
plusieurs milliers 30 ans qui les
préparent les façonne et les cuit pour
les habitants de 800 sur move dans le
loiret et il a une idée bien précise de
ce qu'est une baguette de qualité
devraient baguette c'est quelque chose
qui est pétri par un professionnel dans
son fournil avec un vrai savoir faire
une bonne fin une bonne farine des
breuleux vingt et une longue
fermentation le plus populaire des pains
traditionnels français pourrait être
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
au même titre que la pizza napolitaine
ou le café turc
c'est ce qu'espère en tout cas toute une
profession c'est la baguette artisanale
et le savoir faire artisanal qui va être
mis en valeur
donc à travers ça ça peut permettre aux
clients de différencier notre travail de
d'autres boulangers qui se disent
boulangerie qui ne sont que des cuiseurs
de pain qui n'ont pas de savoir faire et
de de valorisation de la profession
alors pour soutenir le projet les
boulangers se mobilisent ce matin il
distribué dans les rues d'orléans des
baguettes aux passants c'est pour
promouvoir la participation au
championnat mondial de l'unesco d'accord
voilà eh ben c'est super c'est génial
le français on imagine avec le béret ça
va bien sous le bras un donc c'est
typique de la france la baguette
ça reste quand même la valeur une des
valeurs françaises
un levain le pain le fromage et c'est
très bien et ça va se faire on espère
d'accord va c'est génial la baguette à
l'unesco ce n'est pas pour tout de suite
le dossier est entre les mains du
ministre de la culture qui devrait
avancer en 2021
s'il retient sa candidature